this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
we start at 6 30 with some breaking news
this morning metro police right now
investigating a homicide in the west
side of town bianca holman is live at
desert and cimarron near there anyway
with the latest details bianca
hey good morning john so we are in a
subdivision in a neighborhood that is
near deserting and durango and you can
see the yellow tape remains up blocking
part of this road here and this is where
we are at golden and cypress avenue and
where the situation took place is
actually around the corner it's on maple
valley
now within the last five minutes we
actually saw one cruiser leave but
there's still several police vehicles
out here in this area blocked off and
this is the time now that the kids are
getting up and you know walk getting to
the bus and then also people out walking
their dog or doing a morning walkout
workout so you can imagine it's pretty
disturbing to see this happen and so
again details are limited right now but
we do know that
the police is responding to a homicide
in this area so again we're still
waiting a media briefing to share more
details about what actually occurred
in this morning so once we have those we
will be sure to keep you updated here
online and then also on air reporting
live bianca holman 8 news now